in norderstedt in schleswig holstein
gibt es mitten in einem gewerbegebiet
diesen riesigen müllberg jahre lang wird
hier gesetzeswidrig müll deponiert sein
2013 wissen die behörden von den
kriminellen machenschaften trotzdem
haben sie nicht verhindert dass der
illegale müllhaufen immer weiter wächst
die wohnbebauung ist in sichtweite
direkt daneben arbeiten menschen
man weiß nicht was von dort natürlich
überwiegt werden er wird ungünstig steht
hier in unsere richtung ja ein skandal
ist es so oder so ich finde das ganz
schrecklich dieser müllberg da hinten
ist kümmert sich auch kein mensch strom
dass das mal weg kommt wir gehen nach
ständig verzieren laufen an dem bus
vorbei also schön das anders 2008
erhielt der betreiber die genehmigung
auf dieser fläche abfälle zu sortieren
und kurz zu lagern
aber auf dem gelände wird nicht sortiert
schon gar nicht recycelt sondern nach
und nach immer mehr gefährlicher müll
angehäuft darunter hochgefährliches
asbest teerpappe und künstliche
mineralfasern das jahrelange illegale
treiben bleibt den behörden nicht
verborgen
aber erst 2017 macht das landesamt für
umwelt den platz zu und verlangt die
räumung der betreiber der mit dem müll
ein haufen geld verdient hat macht sich
aus dem staub und die behörden erstatten
zwar anzeige aber sonst passiert nichts
die nachbarn haben angst sonst wird sich
um alles gekümmert aber wenn es um die
gesundheit geht von von anwohnern von
mitarbeitern hier bei uns da wird sich
irgendwie da nicht darum gekümmert
die behörde hat die pflicht den
unternehmer zu überwachen und
einzuschreiten wenn das aus dem ruder
läuft
das ist hier nicht geschehen über jahre
hinweg nicht im kieler umweltministerium
kann man keinen fehler bei den
zuständigen behörden erkennen die
kontrolle hat nicht versagt die
kontrolle hat stattgefunden
sie hat auch häufig stattgefunden ist
hat früh anordnung gegeben an den
eigentümern an den eigentümer es hat
auch eine räumung verfügung gegeben 2017
aber die genehm die aufsichtsbehörden
haben den eigentümer und den verursacher
des problems nicht ausreichend an
schneewittchen gekriegt die anwohner
fühlen sich aber trotzdem von den
behörden im stich gelassen
gegen essen sich darum kümmern das geht
nicht und wenn dann muss das erstmal
entsorgt werden dass sich keiner darum
kümmert dass man allein gelassen ist und
kein mensch sich um die belange der
anwohner kümmert demnächst sollen
zumindest die gefährlichen fasern von
der oberfläche abgesammelt werden aber
niemand kann uns verlässlich sagen wann
die komplette illegale deponie geräumt
wird die kosten dafür werden wohl an den
steuerzahlern hängenbleiben